Welcome to the last lecture in the Robotic
Vision course and thanks for hanging in there.
We've talked a lot about the way that images
are formed, how we transform the three-dimensional
world into a two dimensional image. And an
underlying assumption in all of that has been
that the camera is stationary and the object
is stationary.
Well now we're going to consider the case
where the camera is moving. The first thing
we're going to look at then is how does the
image change as the camera moves through space.
And then we're going to flip it around and
say, let's say that I've got an image of something
that looks like this in the image and I want
it to look like this in the image. What we're
going to try to work out is how should the
camera move in order to change the image from
this to this.
The camera has to change its viewpoint and
so we want to work out directly how the camera
should move in order to make that happen.
This is a technique called "Vision Based Control"
sometimes called "Visual Servoing" and is
a topic that I've spent a good deal of my
life thinking about.